[Musica]
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vigenti ed oggi
siamo su ibra game un videogioco rpg
dello stile tipo matt father non è
diciamo lo stile che faccio di solito ma
è uno stile che mi piace tantissimo e
che che avrei comunque fatto prima o poi
quindi non vedevo l'ora di iniziarlo e
preghiamo in dio di non perdere i
salvataggi anche in questo perché
sarebbe una tragedia
comunque ragazzi direi di cominciare
sarà una cosa epica uso già da ragazzino
mi ricordo un cazzo della trama perché
l'avevo letta ma non mi cos'è questo
pomeriggio sotto un cielo grigio invece
i genitori si trovavano presso una
galleria d'arte
poi perché sotto fazzoletto sai quello
che ti ho regalato per il suo compleanno
vieni lo assicuro nella tua tasca ok e
non perderlo è stata la storia più
emozionante che io abbia mai letto in
tutta la mia vita non siete citati
perfetto ci siamo è la tua prima volta
in una galleria d'arte vero io non ho
dubbi che ti piaceva tantissimo ibra non
preferirebbe dei deliziosi c'era rigiri
of dovremo andare alla reception nova
rasoi stare fermo lì per me non è un
problema anzi dovremmo è certo per forza
che se no facciamo lì in piedi le statue
siamo noi delle strutture non lo so
perché ad andare avanti prima due poi
soltanto attenzione di fare silenzio
nelle stanze successive ok e non c'è
nulla di cui ti devi preoccupare credo
questo credo non mi piace per niente non
importa non causare problemi agli altri
visitatori ok ok ci siamo credo io devo
fare le dovute presentazioni i ragazzi
ed i ragazzi della trilogia metti un
collirio perché non si può vedere costi
occhi comunque non importa chi giura che
al giorno in cui capirò che sono andati
in genitori io persi o perso
eccoli eccoli ci sono ho avuto dai
traumi al supermercato quando perdevo
mia mamma quando ero piccolo regalo ma
io vado al piano di sopra perché come
sto rompendo il cazzo ci faccio come
faccio come i bambini quelle che non
hanno voglia di stare a guardare i
quadri al i musei che guardo tutto trovi
i quadri poiché ap stocazzo madonna
ragazzi a prevedere su quattro per
intero che dobbiamo prendere
l'autostrada misti qassimi ragazzi
mancata la voce di botte si è spenta la
musica cioè ci mancava soltanto la
mancata la luce qui
scusi c'è nessuno era pieno di gente qui
sembra lo stadio del ragazzi se spetti
alla luce di botto sento dei passi la
cosa non mi sta piacendo che cazzo
successo ragazzi si è perso cos'è
nessuno nessuno in giro
lo ho perso
la mamma dov'è la mamma maledizione mi
sento esattamente come quando ero nei
supermercati da piccolo che parlavo mia
madre che se mi metto a ballare a
danzare skrillex in mezzo al museo
qualcuno spunta non lo so ragazzi io ho
perso tutti non si io io me ne vado di
quad a [ __ ] via di qui l'entrata è
chiuso benissimo perfetto ragazzi siamo
allora sfondo alla finestra testate
niente perfetto raga non ce la facciamo
ok quello non quella non è tempo era
rossa porca [ __ ] che si può salvare
qui perfetto salviamo perché qua già
inizia a colare sangue e la situazione
si sta facendo di merda ragazzi giorno
per caso dove l'uscita no perché io come
ha fatto uscire zio non fatemi capire
perché quel tizio fuori e voglio capire
come ci è arrivato fuori sua porca
[ __ ] siamo di nuovo al quadro di
prima perché c'è un perché e sporco
ragazzi c'è un qualcosa c'è un liquido
blu che sta scendendo dietro il quadro
vieni cazzola scritto ragazzi sta e
dobbiamo andare
cos'è ai apparsa una scritta scende al
piano di sotto ti farò vedere un posto
segreto ragazzi o ci sono dei pedofili
nel museo sta cosa non me la spiego io
non vorrei andare piano di sotto
sinceramente ma non importa e ci sono
qui ma non prende una minchia caso
dritta l'avevo detto io questo quadro
sembrava troppo vero ragazzi sono mi
sono immerso in un quadro a praga dove
chiatto sono felici tutti comcom com kam
com perfetto allora qualcuno vuole che
io vada da qualche parte prendi la rosa
si prendi la rosa ok si spinge spingono
i tavoli buongiorno senta e lei ha dei
bellissimi capelli mi ricorda vagamente
quella di degrado io prendo st chiave se
non le dispiace
prendi la chiave si ok forse le dispiace
ma io mi levo dai [ __ ] buongiorno
ragazzi cos'è ladro ladro ladro la dono
rubata io la chiave è stata delle mie
mani da sola giuro ragazzi stai si sta
mettendo malissimo devo aprire a porta
bianche qualcuno mi stupri avete per
caso capito perché io da ricordiamo in
sei
ok ok spuntate le braccia che mi hanno
fatto malissimo ma sono ancora vivo
quindi ragazzi se mi toccano mi fanno mi
levano delle rose quella è la mia vita
in poche parole che è perfetto
devo andarci un insetto
io sono un insetto io amo i quadri ma
chi è che faccia cazzo succede ora gava
questa che cazzo si è formata per
parlare con gli insetti va beh non
importa andiamo avanti abbiamo appena
iniziato a giocare figuriamoci non
possiamo attraversare questo buco
perfetto dato nel vigneto grazie ragazzi
a questo il quadro della formica il cui
quadro di una formica si perfetto sempre
che possa essere rimosso dal muro
perfetto prendi lo ho preso il quadro
della fornito a posso mettere perfetto
solo un genio o che la mente non era
quella di calpestare una formica mi
dispiace tantissimo ma equipe c'è un
manichino di qualcosa mi dice che si
muove proprio ciò sto presentimento ma
guarda un po che notizia oddio ragazzi
allora un manichino mi vuole stuprare
appena attraversata ancora anno vi segue
più vero ma è caduta giù caduta giudice
che cazzo ti sta bene [ __ ] provate a
seguirmi mostri di merda finite
malissimo ve lo dico gaio per tutto ad
alcuni sto gioco vi faccio cadere a
morte che cazzo è sta roba
mi sembra un gatto sta cazzo di stanza
fantastico chiesto tizio buongiorno
[Musica]
lo chiama nascondino ma ragazzi poteva
dirmelo subito se voleva giocare a
nascondino cioè io ho mica mi faccio
problemi c'è un quadro molto sinistro no
guarda gli altri erano tutti perfetti ti
giuro erano fantastici
ho trovato la luna si è spenta la luce e
non so che cazzo
ho trovato zucca avrai un premio lo
sapevo ragazzi sono stupratori ovunque
gli sto cazzo di gioco ma gli altri
quelli che cos'erano ok una lancia
convenisse via del mojo ragazzi sono un
[ __ ] se volete dirlo sono un
[ __ ] vecchio e piazza successo una
mano third party in cinque zio ragazzi
poi qualcuno mi spiega che cazzo ci fa
una mano sul mio schermo però non
importa anche sul boston adesso dovrebbe
essermi un cazzo di premio però non
capirà forse questo c'è qualcosa sul
terreno o dai ottenuto un pesce di legno
ok credo che debba metterlo nel
nell'incastro vicino al al gatto di
prima ma se ne va a sta cazzo di maah
perfetto però capire perché non me lo
sta mettendo però vabbè andiamo da parte
di destra perché ancora non l'ho vista
la stazza ordinatissima insomma va bene
ragazzi dove che cazzo dobbiamo fare qui
non è che devo spostare ma perché questa
gli occhi rossi a riportarci la mamma da
ma [ __ ] no cos'è non sbagliato
tasto no stato de merda verifica
aspettate che forse cade ma ragazzi ma
vedete che cazzo di stronzi ho trovato
la cosa a terra un altro pesce di legno
fantastico dobbiamo prendere ok allora
qua ci siamo ok lo ammetto
[Musica]
con permesso che cazzo successo vabbè
andiamo avanti anche se è questo
ma si sputa ma si sputa a terra siamo in
un museo qualcuno tra mai detto no
perché te lo dico io zio non puoi
sputare a terra si stronzo io non ho
capito perché c'è ancora ste cazzo di
braccia che girano chi perché c'è gente
impiccato dalle gambe scazzi non ha
senso ha
buongiorno senti io ti ho liberato tu
sei il mio schiavo 18 47 tombola ragazzi
che cazzo mi rappresenta un 18 non lo so
entriamo qui senza neanche leggere
quello in bianco dice la verità stanno
davanti alla statua andando a destra per
due passi poi a sud per due passi quella
è la risposta a ragazzi ricordatevi 2 a
destra e 2 giu credo che sia così perché
l'ha detto buongiorno senti zio allora
c'è qualcosa nella mano non so che cos'è
devo andare 2 a destra e due giorni c'è
una mattonella allentata sotto i tuoi
piedi
prendi ok sono schiattato di brutto muri
la speranza di un bianco lo sapevo che
era bastarda c'è qualcun altro e micio
qualcos'altro già prefetto a destra di
quattro pazzi e poi a nord di due passi
perfetto allora proviamo andare così 1 2
3 4 1 2
ce l'ho fatto a uno solo e che culo di
merda c'è un numero all'interno della
mattonella quattro ragazzi ma stiamo a
giocà tombola fatemi capire che mio zio
qualcuno ha guardato dove ha messo i
piedi nell'altra stanza ragazzi del
cazzo è successo ok questo non era così
prima credo tra l'altro è ha ucciso il
quadro quello che mi ha aiutato la cosa
è macabra ma vabbè andiamo avanti
ragazzi la cosa è bruttissima non glieli
che cazzo serva nostri numeri 418
trovato per ora anche perché devo
mettere il numero niente un'operazione
ma mista nell'ultimo numero la gaspare
un risultato a caso come faccio nelle
verifiche di matematica di solito io ho
sbagliato proprio come nelle verifiche
di matematica di solito ma che
coincidenza ragazze mi manca l'ultimo
numero allora sono 4 18 è l'ultimo credo
sia più a destra ultima strada stai
attento alle labbra che labbra sexy
sentiti ha fame dami del cibo raga qua
siamo messi malissimo guarda cos'è
guardando più da vicino sembra che ci
sia un numero al centro 9 18 fair 9 fava
[ __ ] potevate amica la calcolatrice
addirittura porca [ __ ] 18 per nove 162
più più 4 perfetto grazie mille per
avermi complicato la vita a 166 allora
dovrebbe funzionare in teoria perfetto
adesso un bel 10 su matematica grazie
ragazzi c'è stata si è sentito un suono
si l'ho sentito anch'io perfetto
entriamo hai ottenuto la mela
dell'albero perfetto me che devo
prendere anche questa che tanto dai
quali si stacca tutto no non devo
prendere anche questa da presumo che la
mela la debba portare al vizio che prima
vuole mangiare si è fatta male ragazza
senta c'è una banana è una bambola ma io
penso fossero persone viva allora meglio
meglio così ragazzo ero convintissimo
del contrario
caputo che mi son cagato addosso ragazzi
non fa niente bene così salviamo la
partita prima di schiattare allora ed ho
portato una mela o fame dami del cibo
dami del cibo dai del cibo ok ok a e
gustosa ti lascerò passare adesso
attraverso la mia bocca
io non mi infilo ridendo ma questa
stupida senta e io non posso entrare
nella bocca degli ok perfetto siamo
entrati bene che esige la ghigliottina
bellissima sostanza mi piace da morire
credo che qualcuno a casa sicuro mondo
anche [ __ ] di brutto lo anche [ __ ]
la salis ali brutta strada sale troppo
un genio 2 casa se non si corre nei
corridoi
io ho visto ha visto veramente
inquietando parecchio quindi prima
troviamo l'uscita prima prima prima
prima cos'è questa è la pensa una mia
madre la ragazza in rosso poca roba
ok ok ferma afferma ok sa cosa sa cos'è
inquietantissimo a cazzo sta cosa è che
la cosa finché tant è che abbia mai
visto in un videogioco è chiusa è chiusa
ha lasciato cadere una chiave perfetto
prendi la chiave premi la chiave veloce
veloce ma tu sei brutta ragazzi è la
cosa più orribile che abbia mai visto in
un videogioco via di qui i cani ragazzi
cani
siamo salvi siamo salvi e la piu era più
brutta di quella che cos'è questo
cliccato non ho letto un suono si è
sentito perfetto ragazzi aperto qualcosa
senza a culo proprio senza neanche
guardare già non sono anche due caccia
ho fatto va bene così
e ancora ma [ __ ] stronzate cazzo
ci fanno dei petali a terra non lo so
c'è del sangue pure la ragazza in blu
non è attaccato al muro e la cosa è
veramente tragica di quella rossa e
bruttissima quella blu non c'è devo
preoccupare forse questa non lo so
buongiorno mi senta lei cos'è ti sta
avvolgendo la chiave è grazie a zia
sentiva che cat ci fai qui a possono
mandare vostro massaggiargli le spalle
fa male ragazzi sua che me frega a me
avevo davanti quel tizio continua a far
così con la lingua
un giorno senta io io io vorrei passare
sei gentilmente si può levare dal cazzo
la chiave ha sbloccato la porta perfetto
un giorno senta lei allora la sua amica
e nella stanza di prima yo yo yo mia
bici credo sia quella mi sembra più una
sfera del drago che una testa ma non
importa
ok ok non mi avvicino non mi avvicino
calma calma ok allora mi scusi lei io
devo devo passare se ma [ __ ] sito
apporto fa misto favore dei ragazzi
concluso qui primo episodio ricordatevi
che comunque questo è un test cioè
diciamo se vi piace lo continuo senza
problemi se non vi piace nuovo continua
non è un problema
fatemelo sapere nei commenti e come al
solito ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto
lasciato argomento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come non idolatrare
schizzare sarà sera per iscritti
iscrivetevi e ci rivediamo in un
prossimo video beh ragazzi